>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> John Kelly: Good
morning, everybody.
Welcome. My name is John Kelly.
I'm a columnist at
the Washington Post.
And the Washington Post is a
charter sponsor of the Library
of Congress National Book Festival.
We want to thank the cochairman
of the festival, David Rubenstein,
and the many National
Book Festival sponsors
who made this event possible.
And you can be like David Rubenstein
and support the festival
with a donation.
Information is in the program.
After our guests speak, there will
be a Q&A and it will be filmed
for the archives and could
appear on a later broadcast.
So if you've always wanted to be
in the collection of the Library
of Congress without having to
write a book, here's your chance.
It may be rude to talk about
people when they're not around,
but this morning we have no choice.
Unfortunately, Kwame Alexander
has had a family emergency
so he can't be here.
But let's talk about him anyway.
Kwame was born in Brooklyn and
raised there and in Chesapeake,
Virginia, in a house where he
said, books were on shelves
on every wall in every room.
My parents forced us
to read every day.
Then we could do other things.
It sounds like the other thing that
Kwame did mainly was write books.
He has written about 24
books, which is more books
than a lot of people read.
They include the picture
books: Animal Ark,
Out of Wonder, and Surfs up.
The novels: Booked
and He Said She Said.
And the playbook: 52 Rules
to Help you aim Shoot
and Score in This Game of Life.
His novel in verse, The Crossover,
won the 2015 Newberry medal
and the Caretta Scott King Award.
Kwame serves as the president of
Book in a Day, a literacy nonprofit
that inspires youth in the
writing and publishing process.
And he recently led a delegation of
20 writers and activists to Ghana,
where they delivered books and
worked on literacy projects,
and I think that may have
inspired part of the book
that we're going to
feature this morning.
And that book is Solo.
It's about Blade Morrison,
the 17-year-old son
of a washed-up rock musician.
I imagine a cross between
Ozzy Osbourne
and Steven Tyler and Lenny Kravitz.
Trying to find his
place in the world.
A solo, of course, is
that part of a song
where the lead guitarist wails away.
And it's also what a pilot has to do
to prove that she knows how to fly.
I think Kwame and Mary mean
both senses of the word.
It's a moving book and
it's a funny book too.
Solo is actually a duet.
Kwame wrote it with Mary Rand
Hess, an author, poet, and editor,
who like Kwame, lives
in Northern Virginia.
She is the author of the picture
books: The Cowpoke Adventures
of Slim and Haskell, and
The Day I Met the Nuts.
She's a cowriter of Animal Ark,
Celebrating our Wild World in Poetry
and Pictures, a book of
animal photography and poetry.
She grew up thinking that
she would be a rock star
in sort of a Pat Benatar mold.
But we already have a Pat Benatar,
so we don't need another one.
Instead we have Mary Rand Hess,
a graduate from George Mason
University with a degree in English,
who wrote this book with Kwame.
Finally, seeing a guitar on
stage is like seeing a gun
on the wall in a checkoff play.
And we are fortunate,
it's going to get played.
We are fortunate to have guitarist
Randy Preston with us this morning.
He has known Kwame Alexander for 25
years, when Kwame produced a play
that Randy was in, The Weight
of Being Black by Glen Allen.
And Randy said, I remember Kwame
selling his books out of his car.
And they lost touch, and then he
heard Kwame being interviewed on NPR
and knew that he had made it.
Randy is a former English
teacher in Washington, DC.
And if you listen to the audiobook
of Solo, you will hear the songs
that Randy wrote for
the characters in there.
So please join me in welcoming
Mary Rand Hess and Randy Preston.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary Rand Hess: Thank you
so much for being here today.
Obviously we're missing Kwame.
And we wish him and his family well.
And we're praying for them.
And we're going to
carry on in a spirit
of Solo in Kwame's honor today.
And let's begin.
So when I decided to write
this book and Kwame decided
to write this book, we
brainstormed together.
And the music that inspired
us throughout our childhood
and adulthood played a big part.
We're big rock fans, as is Randy.
And Randy wrote the awesome music
that Blade writes in this book
and composed the songs that
you're going to hear today.
And so we're very excited
to share that.
But I wanted to start with Blade.
Blade's journey is a
journey of self-discovery.
But it starts in a rough spot.
You know, he doesn't know where he
quite fits in and where he belongs.
Because his father is a
washed-up rock star and an addict.
And his mother is dead.
There's this dream I've
been having about my mother
that scares the holy
night out of me.
And each time I wake from it,
I'm afraid to open my eyes
and face the world that awaits.
The fractured world that used to
make sense but now seems disjointed,
islands of possibility that
float by like 1000 puzzle pieces
that just don't fit
together anymore.
So I think of Chapel and I grab hold
of the only other thing
that matters: my guitar.
So he's grown up under the spotlight
and the press has hounded him,
and he's had to, you know, endure a
lot of his father's antics and show
up to a lot of his shows.
The show. My father,
Rutherford Morrison,
can't stand to be away
from the stage.
He is always craved the spotlight.
Needs it like a drug.
Posing, posturing,
profiling before millions.
An electric prophet,
or so he thinks.
Capturing concert whisperers
and the vapors of his breath
as if his voice is
preparing them for rapture.
My sister and I have always looked
under the stage, beside
it, behind it.
I think he feels -- right
now he puts his hope
in his one saving grace: his
guitar and his girlfriend.
He thinks that Chapel
will kind of save him.
Those eyes will be the death of me.
My gravestone will read:
Here lies a young man
who died inside the gaze of a woman.
I watch the river in
her eyes gallop forth,
fall into them, dive into them.
She smiles.
Those eyes, I can't
escape the depth of them.
The song has ended but
the melody still sings.
From her mouth I can hear a
word -- I can't hear a word.
I'm lost in those two comets
that move across my universe.
I remember the first time
she looked at me, like this.
[ Guitar and Singing ]
So Blade has this guitar and he
has his memories of his mother,
and of course, Chapel, the bridge.
Rutherford gave it to
me in a grand fashion
on a black velvet bench
for my 13th birthday.
A custom-built Eddie Van Halen
Frankenstrat, made of body, ash,
neck, maple, with pickups
tweaked by EVH himself.
Legend has it that Eddie was going
to give it to some king in Africa
or something, but my dad
convinced him to gift it to me.
And that's real cool, I get it.
But what mattered to me
was that when I strummed,
it sounded like mom laughing.
So I named her Sunny
after my mother.
There hasn't been a day, no matter
how crazy or wicked or cruel,
that I haven't held her, knowing
it's the bridge that connects
between heaven and earth.
So that guitar, as you can see,
really kind of helps
him gather his emotions.
But there's problems
that are brewing.
It seems that Blade -- or Chapel's
father really doesn't like him.
And he's going to have
to find a way.
The sky beams as I
search for comfort.
She wraps her arms around my waist.
We hug so tight, the Milky
Way spins on our axis.
Our kiss could save a planet.
This is where I want to be.
This is where I need to be, swaying
softly together toward the stars,
until an earthquake thunders
towards us with an angry --
anger so fierce it'd make 10,000
horses fall and never get up.
Chapel's father is a
6.5 on the Richter.
He stomps up to me in
an ominous black robe
and practically moves
the ground beneath us.
This is it, he roars.
And he tears us completely apart.
Day one. I will never
leave this bedroom again.
I stare at the walls, the
ugly, empty space imprisons me.
There is nothing left
for me if she is gone.
A bare unspoken language that
has no words, no gestures.
A song of sinking silence.
I've texted her 13 times.
[ Guitar and Singing ]
I imagine she jumps into my arms.
We kiss. Our lips like two
special edition book covers.
Keeping our secret story safe inside
the history book of greatest loves.
I tell her I'm leaving.
She insists she's going with me
and that we're never coming back.
We'll compose some deep cuts.
Flip the script, our B side
in a place that's just ours.
I see the light still on
in Chapel's bedroom window.
Why am I so nervous?
Her parents are at church.
I know this because
I called the church.
So who is that laughing around back?
I slowly make my way
around the giggling
and see her silhouette in the dusk.
My girl with Van Dwish,
tickling each other
in our hammock, locking lips.
This can't possibly be happening.
They hear the fallen branch snap
under my feet and look
straight at me.
The cruel moon decides to make
an appearance right now right
over the place where we made out.
[ Guitar and Singing ]
So, Blade, I think he's had it.
He's also discovered a family
secret, and that's kind
of tearing him apart too.
But I don't want to give that away
because you'll have
to read the book.
But he decides he's leaving LA.
I won't miss the Hollywood Hills,
the palm trees, the fake city
and its manufactured lights.
I won't miss the bloodsuckers,
those paparazzi
and the tabloid news
shame because of my name.
Or even those sunsets
over Santa Monica pier.
I won't miss this pain,
and that will never leave.
I won't miss the music under
the trees or the feeling
of finding my own safe
place to breathe.
And now I won't miss her.
So he's going to leave the
jungle, that's what he calls LA.
And he's going to West
Africa, a country named Ghana.
Beautiful country that
he's never been to.
So imagine him landing in
one of the hottest countries
in the world, I would say.
It's right above the equator.
And so he gets off
and he finds a taxi.
And it's a loud country.
There's lots of taxi
drivers honking at him.
We just went to Ghana, so we
experienced the beauty there
and the lively people
and all the taxi drivers
and the beautiful music.
So he gets in a car with a taxi
driver who takes him to Congo,
that's where he thinks
he needs to go.
And they end up at a junction.
After two hours of winding,
crating roads, in a beat up Honda
with no shock absorbers to
absorb the shock of 47 miles
of unpaved roads with
scattered potholes,
the taxi driver finally stops.
Congo, he says, and points to a long
road on the right of the junction.
Thank you Mr. Easia responds.
How far of a walk?
Not far, maybe four, maybe
five minutes -- kilometers.
So he gets out of the car and
he has to walk many miles.
And when we were in Congo
recently, the roads washed out.
We were going to help out in a
village and meet the people of Congo
and work with the children.
And we were dedicating a beautiful
library, and they were working
with both us to get this library
done, but there had been rain.
And so the road was washed out.
And it was not easy
getting there, was it?
And I just remember that
we bumped around a lot.
Randy, what did you think?
>> Randy Preston: You ever sat
in the back of a school bus?
Just imagine that amplified
by three or four times.
And relentless, just relentless.
It was -- the village was gorgeous.
>> Mary Rand Hess:
Wasn't it beautiful?
>> Randy Preston: Absolutely.
>> Mary Rand Hess: What
did you think of Congo?
>> Randy Preston: I'd been to
Africa before but never to Ghana.
And I read the book before I went,
so I was like, oh, this is familiar,
this looks like the
stuff I've seen before.
But it was such a beautiful place
because the people are
comfortable with who they are.
And that's not something
you find everywhere.
They're comfortable in their skin.
They're happy to be there.
They want you to be a part of what's
happening and what's taking place
in their village, because
they think it's cool.
And that's not something
you see a lot in the States,
so I enjoyed that part of it.
>> Mary Rand Hess: Well, I
think when Blade's there,
he learns a lot about himself.
And I don't want to
give too much away.
>> Randy Preston: No, don't do that.
>> Mary Rand Hess: Yeah.
Again, you want to read the book.
But he has a revelation, and
this is what I think is kind
of his motto while he's there.
We are the sum of moving
parts and adjustable hearts.
And so I'm going to try to
find the poem Congo to read
to you all if I can grab it.
Do you know how many
minutes we have left?
I'm just curious.
14 minutes -- 20 minutes, okay.
So bear with me as I find Congo.
[ Guitar and Singing ]
Congo is a village
of brown and green.
Apron of mother earth.
Gray puffy sky.
A temperamental sea that swallows.
That keeps me looking and
laughing to the clouds.
Today I saw a sign near a small
lake that read: no drowning.
Red and green buckets of water
traveled miles suspended in air
to glorious rhythms of routine under
hidden sun of orange fiery promises.
The smiles here are abundant.
A crest of waves across
faces, young and old.
The fly with wings of
kings and queens in search
of trees rooted in ancient ground.
History with arms that reach and
give and give crowns of flowers
and coconut milk the ambrosia
feeding my wandering soul.
It's about the music back to me.
Most gatherings are here
under the big coconut tree.
This place covered in brilliant sun
and a humbling moon captures joy
and song and dance of women and
men happy to be singing and alive
with sounds that never sleep.
Past the magic dust dreams.
Here I can lift my
hands into the sky,
pull down the promises
into my palms.
In other words, this
place is beautiful.
[ Guitar and Singing ]
Thank you, Randy, that
was beautiful.
Will you give Randy
a round of applause.
[ Applause ]
So I thought we'd just give
you a glimpse into Solo.
It's a song -- well, it is
really a song, is what it is.
Its an epic song of a love
letter to rock 'n roll
and to family and to
finding yourself.
So we're up here now
and we are ready
to take any questions
if you have questions.
>> Randy Preston: Ask away.
>> Mary Rand Hess: Please do.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Randy Preston: The
poetry in the book --
I read the whole book as
I was writing the songs.
So Kwame said, okay,
write a song about this
and then make sure Mary likes it.
I was like okay.
So I wrote a song and I think
one of the first ones --
we went through some drafts of them.
They're like, no, that's not
right, it's got to be more epic.
So it was definitely informed by
the book and by their experiences
and then just thought about the
experiences of the characters.
You know, what's the
character thinking about.
The last song I sang, we wrote
that for his graduation, you know.
And I was thinking and,
you know, we talked,
what would a 17-year-old
kid think about.
You know, what are the highlights
of that that we need to pull out.
So it was all informed by the story.
>> Mary Rand Hess: So it was
a song he was supposed to sing
at his graduation but didn't get to.
But you'll have to read the
book again to find out why.
>> Randy Preston: We can't tell you.
>> Mary Rand Hess: But
he does get to sing it
at some point in the book.
And so Kwame and I, you know, we
worked on the book together first,
like Randy said, and then he used
his brilliance to create the songs.
And when he came over with the song
that he just performed,
I literally was a mess.
I was crying at Kwame's
dining room table.
>> Randy Preston: We all were.
We were like, this is perfect.
>> Mary Rand Hess: It was great.
Emotional moment.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Hi. You wrote the book
together with Kwame Alexander.
What was that process like?
Were you guys together
like face-to-face, or
did you do it emails?
Or how did that work
writing collaboratively?
>> Mary Rand Hess:
That's a great question.
Well, Kwame and I both
love collaboration.
And so we did a lot of -- we met
in person but we also did a lot
of texting back and
forth and emails.
And he might have written 10
poems and then I've written 10,
and then we exchanged them.
I mean, literally I think we
both touched every poem that was
in the book in every corner
of the book in every center
and outside and in between.
So we really, we both
put our hearts in 100%.
And he's just so great, knowing
when something is working
and not working too.
So I could write something
and he's be like, I'm sorry,
Rand -- he calls me Rand.
We're going to have
to take this one out.
And it's always -- you know
how they always say it's your
little darlings.
So it was hard.
Sometimes we'd have
to cut some poems.
In fact, we cut about 200
pages out of the book.
So you see how thick this book is?
It was going to be like that.
We had an editor who
was like, cut this down.
So any other questions?
>> Okay, I was wondering
about the audible version.
And if Randy's songs, are
you performing, Randy?
>> Randy Preston: Yes, ma'am.
So the audiobook -- I
think, yeah, it's just me
and the guitar and
that's what we did.
Kwame's narrating it,
which is awesome.
He did a really good job of it.
And yeah, check it out.
>> Yeah, that seems like
that would be wonderful.
>> Mary Rand Hess: In fact,
since he couldn't be here today,
I recommend if you have a
moment to grab the audiobook,
you can hear him read,
since he wasn't here today.
And he is just phenomenal
at reading this book,
and Randy's music to go with it.
>> Randy Preston: Yeah,
he's an actor.
He's a performer.
He knows how to present things.
And so when he's presenting
them, he tells such a good story.
It's really compelling.
Go out and get it, it's good.
>> Mary Rand Hess: And
we might be biased, but.
>> Randy Preston: We're
a little biased.
>> Mary Rand Hess: Anyone else?
>> Hi. We were here a couple of
years ago and saw Mr. Alexander.
And he was talking
about the possibility
of a movie for the crossover.
Where do you see this book going?
>> Mary Rand Hess: That's
a really great question.
It would be my dream to see it
on the screen and as a musical.
I think it would make
a great musical.
With all the music
and the storyline.
So that's a great question.
We have some things
floating out there.
>> Randy Preston: There's
some things in the works.
>> Mary Randy Hess: Some things
in the works, some interests.
So we'll see what happens.
Very excited.
>> Thank you so much for
sharing your talents today.
I was wondering about how we
could hear more of your music,
besides the audio version.
Is there other outlets?
>> Randy Preston: Yeah,
yes, there is.
Yeah, I'm traveling to balance it.
Up to about a year and a half
ago, I was teaching full time
in a Washington, DC charter school.
So recently I'm like, oh, no,
I have to write more music.
So I'm doing that.
Hopefully by the end of
September, we will have three
of the songs from this on iTunes.
That's what we're working on now.
So keep your ears open for that.
And that'll be cool.
And I'll be doing my own
little stuff in between there.
We'll talk about that as well.
But thank you for the question.
>> Hi. Excuse my ignorance but
who wrote the poetry in this book?
>> Mary Rand Hess: I'm sorry?
>> The poetry?
>> Mary Rand Hess: The
poetry in the book?
Kwame and I wrote the
poetry in the book.
So all the poems that you read
in the book are written
by Kwame and myself.
>> The verbal version of the
book will have the songs?
>> Mary Rand Hess: Yes.
The songs that you hear in
the book that are written
by the character Blade,
Randy here wrote those songs.
And there's four songs in this
book that are original, you know,
it's original music
that he, Randy, wrote.
And it's on the audiobooks.
It's in here, the words are in here.
But if you want to hear it live,
performed live in a studio.
>> I thoroughly enjoyed
the songs and I would
like to get the other version of
the book that has the songs in it.
>> Randy Preston: Thank
you very much.
>> Mary Rand Hess: I
highly recommended it.
Thank you.
>> Randy xxx: I recommend
it as well.
>> Mary Rand Hess: Anyone
else have a question?
Well, thank you so
much for being here.
[ Applause ]
And I know Kwame missed
being here today,
and thank you for coming to see us.
I know that he was here in spirit
and he appreciates all of you.
So have a wonderful time here at the
festival and go out and find Solo.
Thank you.
>> Randy Preston: It's
good, it's good stuff.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.GOV.